[Musique]
les choses ont pas être et j'ai donc
nous le terme de réforme ne fait pas
peur et de la corne peut être bonne
boîte pour est mauvaise il ya cette
réforme il ya des points qui sont les
progrès notamment des personnes vers et
effectivement baissé leurs prestations
et c'est peut-être ce que la dernière la
réforme la philosophie qui mauvaise
philosophie ça doit l'être
permettre à des gens de rebond durant
leur donne en effet des de sécurité
alors que la philosophie générale a
l'air d'être nous voulons générer des
économies et faire des économies et le
reste via le reste suivra et le dernier
point que la cftc réacteur 2 10 l'argent
du chômage c'est l'argent des
entreprises et pour une entreprise ce
sont les actionnaires les salariés et
dirigeants
c'est notre argent laissez-nous gérer
notre argent où nous faisons la
démonstration depuis 60 ans pas travail
syndicats de la capacité à jouer
correctement cet argent et à servir les
intérêts de salariés qui sont en
recherche d'emploi la réforme de
l'assurance chômage est ce qu'elle est
juste et équitable - il semble que non
il me semble que bon d'abord et c'est
assez évident on a bien compris que il
ya une dégressivité il ya un recul de
l'ouverture des droits
et puis il ya une manipulation ou 6 sur
le calcul de ce fameux salaire de
référence
on est dans un contexte quand même
difficile d une pandémie va y avoir une
hausse du chômage
et puis finalement ben on se retrouve
avec des principes qu un peu où quatre
personnes sur dix cas demandeurs
d'emploi sur dix vont vont perdre
finalement par rapport à une situation
antérieure
il y à de très fortes inégalités
territoriales
tu sais pour dire que le
assurance chômage va être efficace parce
qu'on est en déficit parce que ça va
générer quelques recettes enfin quelques
recettes à imiter le déficit oui si
c'est juste pour dire ça bon on retourne
presque dans le piège de l'année des
réformes des d'europe des retraites s'il
ya du système à points
voilà un petit peu je pense que je pense
qu'il ya quelque part un petit peu de
problèmes le timing est peut-être de
responsabilité et d'engagement en
matière de politique économique joue pas
contre fait plus de politique économique
aujourd'hui donc regardons les choses et
la cftc c'est ce que nous demandons que
on prenne le temps de poser les choses
et d'en débattre réellement pas des
grand messes qui servent à rien mais les
partenaires sociaux encore une fois
patronat syndicats avec pour nos
différences on sait traiter ces
problèmes regardez bien comment les
caisses de retraite sont gérés
aujourd'hui par les partenaires sociaux
elles sont gérées je ne crois pas un
instant ce qu'on appelle en réalité
réforme ce ne sont pas des réformes de
politiques économiques souvent réalité
des réformes administratives aux
techniques et donc on continue c'est
comme l'histoire des retraites à faire
beaucoup d'administratif et de technique
on a l'impression qu'on est un petit peu
je dirais gouverné par par des
technocrates un petit peu banal de le
dire je m'en excuse mais ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que la réforme
normalement souhaite une réforme de
politique économique aujourd'hui en
matière de pouvoir d'achat c'est la
formation professionnelle
c'est les métiers de demain c'est le
monde de demain c'est les technologies c
d innovation énormément de métier vont
gagner en pouvoir d'achat en se formant
aux innovations du monde de demain ça on
n'en parle pas du tout alors ça
franchement s'en fiche complètement
et malheureusement j'espère que je crois
je soupçonne que soupçonne
une démarche de manoeuvre en fait qu'ils
sont extrêmement réduites
en réalité ces problèmes sont techniques
donc sont plus difficilement à bande
armée
mais puisqu'il s'agit de débat il ya le
rôle de journaliste ou journalistes de
poser des question de revenir sur les
questions et dans ses intérêts
politiques seront obligés de s'engager
de réponse on verra et ne veulent pas ou
qui ne peuvent pas répondre et donc je
crois que là quand je regarde les débats
je vois les questions qui sont posées
sujet à des journalistes à ce sujet
ainsi une anxiété ça suffit ça suffit on
est à vierzon bien vive une anémie
incroyable donc why not pourquoi pas
l'assurance chômage ou en août pour les
élections régionales bon je trouve que
le sens de l'intérêt général et est plus
important au regard du thème qu'il ait
choisi un aussi si je peux le dire ainsi